Now, we reached a part which is
the third point that mentioned
and That is?
The
[Silence]
really is. What is this world?
It's an illusion Doesn't mean
it doesn't exist. It exists.
We're here. It's tangible. but
it's an illusion. All of its
pleasures are an illusion.
Well, not
Allah says the life of this
world is but a temporary,
transient, illusionary
enjoyment. That's what he says.
What does that mean? It means
that it's brief. No matter how
long you live, it's still not
enough. First of all, the human
being can never be satisfied.
And second of all, it is
something that is very fast and
it's getting faster and faster
If you can believe that.
[Silence]
There was a lot of there was a
lot of time. It felt time
was longer. You could get more
accomplished. Let me give you
an example of accomplishment.
You want to get an example of
that? How many people here can
read one hundred pages of a
book every single day from the
time they are born until the
time they die. How many?
None of us, right? Okay
He passed away in the year 3
and ten We took all his works
and his most expansive and most
important work is that's what
he's most known for but he has
other books. There's many other
books and they calculated how
much he wrote. They said and
Imam of by the way, he passed
away in his nineties. They
said, in order for him to have
written, the amount that he
wrote from the moment he was
born until he died, he would
have had to write 40 pages a
day.
40 pages a day writing. Which
obviously is much more
difficult than reading. Where
did he get the time to learn
all of this in order to write
it in that time?
Traveled the world and
memorized three
000 narrations. 300, hundred
thousand. And he compiled his
book, Sahih Al Bukhari in 15
years.
Took him 15 years to write it.
But that's not the only book he
has. He has other books as
well.
Right?
Where did he get the time to
travel
Between all these places.
Memorize all these narrations
and then put it in this book.
Has more than 100 books that he
wrote. And he did not live a
long life. He died in his 60s.
And every one of his books is a
landmark in the Islamic
Library. Who died as well, a
young man. Died in the year
728. His writing completely
have never, never reached us
because many of his books were
destroyed during the
inquisitions and during the
crusades and also by his other
enemies that were jealous of
him.
He wrote a book that was a of
the Quran. He wrote a book on
Tefsir,
Surat, Kulhu, All than 10
volumes.
Right? Where did they get the
time to do all of this? If we
had a hundred pair of glasses,
huh? We can't even get through
two or three of these books. I
mean, if I were to be able to
read all of what we have from
or I would consider myself
someone who has achieved
something great that many have
not. Why is it that we can't do
that these days? Why?
The prophet
prophesied. That near the end
of time, when the hour is near
That time would start to become
shorter. He said in Sahih Al
Bukhari which means that time
will become shorter. Does time
itself literally move faster?
No. It's the same time. It
doesn't change. Everybody gets
an equal opportunity. Correct?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentioned that time is the same
speed as it always was. What
does that mean? In the
that that number of months in
the book of Allah when he
created the heavens and earth
are 12 months. Of them are
foresacred. Time is the same.
We are the ones who changed.
What does that mean? We are the
ones who changed. It means that
because of the prevalence of
sin. And because of the
prevalence and permeation of
decadence there is no in our
time. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has taken away the the blessing
of time. So a person can
achieve what they used to be
able to achieve because we live
in a sinful decadent time.
People have become sinful.
People have become decadent.
and because of that, when
decadence permeates a people,
time starts to seem it's
shorter. The prophet said in
Muslim Imam Ahmed, That
[Silence]
The
one hour and 1 hour will be
the strike of a match.
That's how fast it will go by.
Notice, look, look at your
lives. Look how much you have
accomplished and I'm not
speaking about accomplishment
in Islamic sciences or writing
books or anything that.
I'm just speaking about your
day. Your daily routine. You
want to go out and buy
groceries and you want to get
this and you want to do that
and you want to do that and you
want to get the oil change and
how many things can you do in a
day? How fast does the day go?
Even if you get up at six: 00
in the morning, how many things
can you accomplish? very many
because decadence has permeated
our place and time and so of
the repercussions of that is
that Allah removes from our
time. May Allah forgive us. May
Allah forgive us. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala just accept
what little we have to offer
and grant us greatness from it.
Not because we deserve it but
because he is Allah. We ask
Allah at from the deepest of
our hearts. and so, the issue
is this, knowledge of the Quran
and Sunnah. This is one of the
greatest things that will open
your heart to more. As the wise
men of ancient have said,
they said, whoever
implements what he knows Allah
will teach him what he does not
know. knowledge and I want to
make this clear, okay? Whenever
we see in the Quran in Sunnah,
the word knowledge it is it is
referring to the Quran in
Sunnah. Quran
[Silence]
Because they were there and
they saw it in action. He said
in his
[Silence]
The prophet Muhammad they are
his generation They are the
ones that he perfected with his
hand. And they witnessed
revelation coming to the
prophet they were there. They
were able to feel and taste the
terrain. They watched prophet
moving. One day, spent with the
prophet Muhammad could equal 10
years of studies of a scholar
in our time. One day, just
watching him as he prays, as he
sits, as he speaks, as he
dresses, as he walks, that 1
day of knowledge could place in
your heart the light that
couldn't be achieved in 10
years of studying. We're so far
away from him. Yes, the Quran
in Sunnah has been preserved
but we will never be the
companions there's a book
called Rawi.
Is a book which was was
authored by the great scholar
of Egypt who passed away in the
year 9 eleven.
He said in his book Tedriba
Rawi. Listen to this statement.
Listen to how powerful this
statement is. He said, one
moment, of meeting the prophet
Having believed in him. and you
meet him while you believe in
him. Will place in the heart a
light that cannot be comparable
to any light or knowledge that
anyone who comes after. One
moment. If you meet the prophet
for one moment believing in
him. It will place in the heart
a light that can never be
achieved by anyone else who
hasn't had that experience.
This is what he said. and this
is why the companions are so
special. So, what is knowledge?
When
tells us one of the greatest
things that will open your
heart to the light of Allah is
knowledge of the Quran and
Sunna, what does this mean? It
means knowing what Allah said,
knowing what the prophet said,
knowing how the companions
understood what Allah and his
prophet said.
that's knowledge. Because the
Quran could be interpreted in
many ways. Isn't that correct?
Couldn't we, couldn't we,
couldn't we prove anything with
the Quran? We have people now
that justify murder and they
use the Quran to justify it,
correct? They blow people up
and they blow up little old
ladies and they blow up and
they kill each other. All in
the name of what? Allah said,
right? And we have other people
that drink alcohol and do drugs
and our terrible and they use
the Quran as an evidence for
that. Yes. What does this mean?
This means that you can find
whatever you're looking for in
the Quran. but there's only one
correct understanding The Quran
is ambiguous enough that you
can find whatever you want in
it, right? but it is specific
enough to where you understand
it how. According to whose
understanding. Okay, so we have
a verse here. We understand it.
How do we know that we
understood it correctly? Well,
we look at the prophet what he
said. And we look at the
companions and see what they
understood it to mean. Because
Allah prays the companions from
amongst all people. In the
Quran, didn he said
he said if they believe the non
Muslims in what you gesturing
to the prophet Muhammad and his
companions that's when this
verse was revealed. If they
believe in what you all have
believed in, they have become
guided. So this means that the
companions are the yardstick
for correct understanding. this
up. What does this mean? We
believe in the Quran We follow
the Quran. We follow the Sunnah
according to the understanding
of who the companions of
correct? Because we know for
sure that the companions got it
right. They got it right
because Allah told us in the
Quran that he is pleased with
them. And there is only one
path to the pleasure of Allah.
So, for them to be for them to
have Allah pleased with them
that means that they had gotten
that one path. So, it is never
to be said, you know, Abu Bakr
said this but I said this, you
know, he understands, I
understand too. He's a guy and
I'm a guy. No. You're a guy and
he's a man and he's not just a
man, he's a companion and he's
the greatest companion of all
of the companions of any
prophet according to the
consensus of all of the
scholars of Islam. You never
compare yourself to a
companion. And say I am you
know, similar to this companion
or I can understand he
understood. No. This Quran was
revealed in their language.
When it was recited to them,
they didn't need the prophet to
nitpick and say will will cause
some will all this that we have
to learn now We're 1, 5100
years away from the prophet yes
the Quran is preserved just
it was revealed yesterday.
And the sunnah is is preserved
just it was spoken by the
prophet yesterday. But our
circumstances have changed. I
mean how many of us have really
seen a camel in real life? How
many of us have really seen a
camel? How many of us have
really sat with a camel for an
entire day? And watch the
behavior of a camel. How many
of us lived in the desert? How
many of us know the trees that
are referred to in the Quran?
How many of us know the
examples and parables that are
given to us in the Quran? Very
few of us. Very few of us. So
our circumstances of changed.
means that we misunderstand the
Quran. We want to read the
Quran and then understand it
based on our circumstances.
That is incorrect. We
understand the Quran based on
the circumstances of who? The
prophet and this is a point I'd
to make. Are you ready for
this point? I hope everybody is
listening. The prophet received
the Quran in a way that would
touch the hearts specifically
of the people who are around
him at the time it was
revealed. What does that mean?
So, for example, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
that one of the fruits of
paradise are grapes, correct?
Someone may say, grapes make me
sick. I hate grapes. What's so
great about that? You can have
in paradise anything you want,
right? But he mentioned grapes
a lot because it was a delicacy
for the people at that time.
You can whatever you like. He
mentions pomegranates. He
mentions olives. Are these
delicacies where we come from?
Maybe, maybe not. The point is
not to be taken that you only
receive that. The point is to
be taken that, the most, the
greatest, utmost of delicacies
of the time of the prophet that
was what was promised to those
people. We can extra from this
that the greatest of our
delicacies will also be
available as well. Do you
understand? The description of
the houses of paradise. The
description of the women of
paradise, the description of
the food of paradise. The
description of the gardens of
paradise. All of that is what?
Circumstantial. It is not
limited to that. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said He
said that they have, in it,
whatever they want
So, one of the descriptions,
I'm going to give you an
example, okay?
An example of this,
is that Allah
promised coolness. To the
people of paradise, that they
will be in
they will be in a that is
extended. It's not hot If you
are an Eskimo living in Alaska
in the freezing cold, does that
appeal to you?
Do you want coolness or do you
want some heat?
You want some heat, right?
But it was revealed to people
in the desert. So, that
appealed to them. Do you
understand? It doesn't mean
that there's no warmth in
paradise. Likewise, another
example. Allah mentions that
the women of paradise are What
does mean? Means that they have
very wide eyes.
Okay?
Beauty is subjective, correct?
In certain parts of China and
Japan,
traditionally, if a woman has
big eyes, that is considered to
be ugly.
It's true. They say that the
smaller the eyes are and the
more beady they are, the more
beautiful she is. Does that
mean that somebody from that
area will not have that's what
he desires in paradise? Yes,
this is not a limiting
description.
This is merely descriptions
that appeal to the Arabs at
that time. That's what they saw
as beautiful.
That's what they saw as
tasteful. That's what they saw
as comfortable. So Allah
mentions that. That's why he
says subhanahu wa ta'ala. He
says, the parable, the example
of the paradise that the
righteous have been promised.
It's an example. It's not the
only thing. It's not a limiting
example. It doesn't mean it's
limited to that. Especially
things like
figs and so forth, olives, and
all these things.
So, this is an example of what
paradise has.
I want people to understand
that.
Because a person can have
anything they want in paradise.
Anything.
Now, a person's mind may be
dirty here in this life. and
they may say, well, what if I
want such and such which is
haram and indecent. You're not
going to want that if you get
to paradise because your heart
has been purified. Your heart
has been cleaned of all the
filth that you have picked up
in this world and turned turn
to love. Do you understand? The
same thing with the rivers of
wine that are in paradise. Wine
is disgusting
in this life. But the Arabs
used to view it as something
that is of high value. Made
them brave. It was able to help
them as a sedative in war and
it made them more generous.
When they get drunk, they start
giving out money, right? And
that's why they named grapes
They used to refer to grapes as
what? Al Qaram. What you, what
is Al
Carm? called grapes, the source
of generosity. That's what they
used to call grapes And so the
prophet said, look at how
beautiful this narration is. He
said, do not call grapes the
source of generosity, rather
the source of generosity is the
heart of the believer. Subhan
Allah. Right? So, they used to
love wine because of what it
did but wine this world has
very negative effects too,
doesn't it? It makes you vomit,
it makes you want to go to the
bathroom a lot, it makes you
dizzy, and lose your mind, and
it also gives you a very
terrible headache the next day.
Okay? And so, even at best
said, that the wine of paradise
is free of four things.
vomiting urination, headache,
and mindlessness. So, you will
get all of the pleasure that
you feel in your body from it
but you will not get any of the
displeasure that comes along
with it. So, this is what we
mean by understanding the Quran
and Sunnah. A lot of people
think that they come to me, you
know, a lot of people come to
me. They say, I want to learn
the Quran in Sunna. I want to
be a or something. They say
something that, right? I
want to, I want to come a
scholar. What is scholarship
Scholarship is not the amount
of verses or narrations that
you know. Scholarship is
understanding everything that
you know. And implementing it.
That is what knowledge is. And
this takes us back to our main
point. When Allah says Muhammad
is knowledge in the diction of
the Quran and Sunnah. When the
pro
or when Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala refers to knowledge.
Okay? This knowledge, what is
it? We said knowledge is the
Quran and the sunnah according
to the understanding of the
companions, correct? But that's
not it. That's not it alone.
Knowledge in the Quran and
Sunnah when we refer to
knowledge, it is only what is
implemented.
I'm going to give a pause there
for you to take that in Only
what you implement is
considered knowledge. So, if
you know something from the
Quran and you don't implement
it, you are not considered to
be knowledgeable of that verse.
That's not knowledge in the
Quran and Sunnah. Do you
understand? If I know a
narration and I can recite it
but I do not implement it, it's
not knowledge according to
Allah.
Knowledge we could say facts
and knowledge. You can take a a
a verse from the Quran It in
itself contains knowledge. But
when it comes into your mind,
it can either stop at your
throat or go into your heart.
If it stops at your throat,
it's nothing but facts. You are
now just regurgitating facts.
But if it enters into your
heart and you implement it, now
it is knowledge. That is what
is meant by knowledge in the
Quran and Sunnah. Do you
understand? this is something
that is very important point. A
very important point is for us
to understand that knowledge is
number one. Let's define the
source of knowledge. The source
of knowledge is Allah said the
prophet said, according to the
understanding of the
companions, correct? Okay, we
got that. Second of all, in
order for you to be a person of
knowledge, you have to
implement that knowledge If you
do not implement that
knowledge, you are ignorant of
that thing, right? I'll give
you an example of this from the
Quran. Musa Alaihi Salam had a
problem with his people. There
was a murder that took place.
Nobody knew who committed the
murder. So, they came to Musa
Alaihi Salam and said somebody
was murdered and we need to
find out who the culprit is.
received revelation from Allah.
So they came to Musa Alaihi
Salam. Who is Musa? Can you
imagine the majesty of Musa
Alaihi Salam? Huh? I mean, if
we imagine the majesty
[Silence]
story in the Quran and for good
reason. Musa Alaihi Salam is an
incredible man of strength and
durability and robustness. A
man of will sheer will, and
devotion to Allah Musa Alaihi
Salam is the one who was chosen
from all of the prophets. To be
the one who was spoken to
directly from Allah. wherever
he was When Allah wished to
speak to him, he spoke to him
directly. That's why he is
called
did this happen with the
prophet Muhammad Yes, it
happened. It happened a few
times. Either in sleep or on
but it wasn't a consistent
thing. This is something that
was consistent with Musa. When
he when Revelation came to him,
it was Allah speaking directly
to him. On his first meeting
with Allah. He comes to a tree
that he thinks is a fire. And
when he reaches there, he finds
that the tree is not on fire.
The tree is resonating light
with no flame. and when he gets
there, Allah speaks to him. At
that tree and he says, I
indeed, am Allah, your lord.
And Allah teaches him a lesson
on his way. What was his first
lesson? His first lesson was
trust Allah more than you trust
your own body. That was his
first lesson. What do you mean
by that? Meaning that?
He was to throw his staff down.
His staff turned into a serpent
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
So it's a giant snake that is
moving with swiftness and
quickness. How terrified would
you be? Naturally, as humans,
we are afraid of snakes, okay?
When it turned into a snake,
what was the first thing Musa
did? Tell me, tell me. What's
the first thing he did? he ran
away
He ran away and didn't even
look back. But then Allah told
him come back. Grab that snake.
all of his body was screaming
to him. Stay away from that.
That is death. But Allah was
telling him, grab that snake.
Ignore what you see, ignore
what you smell, ignore what you
hear, ignore what you feel,
ignore what you taste, and grab
that snake. And so he reached
down and he grabbed it. That
was his first lesson. What was
the lesson? I now trust the law
more than I trust my own body.
That was the first lesson. This
is Musa Alaihi Salam. He was
taught directly by Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. Time is
getting short So, this is the
majesty of Musa. Musa Alaihi
Salam, the one who stood in
front of Faraon, a little
shepherd man with his, with his
brother beside him, he couldn't
even speak properly. He would
say something and then his
brother would speak more
eloquently for him. Right? And
in spite of that, he stood
there with the with the courage
of a thousand lions. in front
of and he said,
great demands to have. So, this
is Musa. Musa Alaihi Salam, his
people know this about him.
Does this a man that is
joking around with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Does this
sound a man who would joke
about revelation? No. It's way
beyond the majesty of Musa. But
his people couldn't respect
him. So they came to him and
they said there's a murder. We
need some, we need you to find
out who's the culprit from
Allah. So, he received
revelation. Allah has commanded
you to slaughter a cow. They
said we're asking you about a
murder and you're telling us to
slaughter a cow. Are you making
fun of us? That's what they
asked him. to show you the
disrespect Musa Alaihi Salam
said,
he said, I seek refuge in Allah
that I be of the ignorant. What
does that mean? It means making
fun of a Muslim or making fun
of the revelation of Allah is
ignorance. Even if you know
that it is haram. You
understand? So, knowledge in
the Quran in Sunnah is only
considered knowledge when you
implement lament it As soon as
you stop implementing it, it is
no longer considered knowledge
with Allah. It is now facts. It
has moved from the heart up to
the throat. You can say it but
you don't have conviction of it
because if you have conviction
of it, it will force you. To
implement it. That's the true
nature of the Quran.
When So, we will end with that
today. We understood now the
third point of and that is
knowledge. We have discussed
tonight. Alhamdulillah, what
not the sources of knowledge
are in Islam, the Quran, the
Sunnah, according to the
understanding of the companions
and we have discussed what is
considered knowledge, what it
interacts with the human being
in the book of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
move on to the next point.
thank you all for coming. We
ask Allah to grant us wisdom
Because whoever is granted true
wisdom from the book of Allah
and the of the prophet then he
has been given the greatest
that any man could be given.